vous adorez zoug jacques s'inquiéter sur
france 2 qu'un peu de rhum surtout avec
beaucoup de roms on peut pas vous en
donner ici
forcément puisque bien sûr à boire avec
modération c'est moi qui suis obligé de
faire le boulot du ministre c'est pas
grave
non mr jack on peux pas vous le donner
mais mais jack on a envie de faire
quelque chose avec vous on a envie de
faire
le danse avec jack lang c'est parti avec
moi et avec moi jack honnêtement vous
inquiétez pas mais il venait avec moi je
n'ai que moi vous allez voir alors cette
année on a remarqué que le casting de
danse avec les stars étaient un petit
peu faiblard donc venez au centre les
chroniqueurs vont vous rejoindre à
chaque fois vous allez entendre notre
nom les chroniqueurs vous allez voir et
vous avez dansé sur les différents
styles de musique vous suivre vous vous
danser pour jack d'accord attention
c'est parti
attention ça va partir on y va j'accuse
et sa partenaire
isabelle morini bosc
j'ai
ça tangue
soro attention de zelda zouk endiablé
jack lang et son partenaire gilles
verdez
bien que ça m'arrive jamais dû perdre
mais lui il faut le calmer
allez passer à la 4 passes à l'a4 à l'a4
à l'est voilà ça va lui faire du bien
jack lang et sa partenaire
enora malagré
messieurs l'adorent djak et djack et je
prends une dernière avec valérie quand
même c'est parti écoutez a laissé partir
une salsa jack lang et sa partenaire
valérie bègue
paris
non
à
et attention vous la surface avec jack a
réussi en passe à gaillac la dernière
danse attention sur une chemise jacquiau
et tous les chroniques de traits pmp
m
joe baca datacell ça je pense je pense
que ça restera dans les annales de la
télévision française est ce que vous
l'avez vu comme jack reste toujours
classe c'est la seule personne fait
jeudi mais classe quand même voyons pas
tous les traits tu disais tout à l'heure
on se souvient que de lui mais ya que
lui et ses prix de faire deux choses
comme ça et si s'amuser et monde est
terminée vous faire quatre dans ce
différend